every Thursday we highlight stories
affecting consumers these days
everything from makeup to meals can be
delivered to your door more and more
people are signing up for subscription
services like meal preparation kits
clothing rentals a 20-18 survey found
Americans spent an average of two
hundred and thirty seven dollars and 33
cents on subscriptions each month
including cell phone service that's a
hundred ninety seven percent higher than
what people surveyed originally
estimated Wall Street Journal personal
technology columnist Joanna Stern makes
the case to stop wasting money on
unnecessary monthly subscriptions
welcome I'm here to save you all money
thank you why is this subscription
economy taking off so in the tech world
there's something called
software-as-a-service or sass it's not a
bad word but it's sort of is a bad word
it's the idea that everything has become
a service everything's always evolving
getting better right we used to buy a
piece of desktop software and it would
be we buy it for one time and then we
buy it again but no now we always pay
for something because it's always
getting better and that's the case with
everything from Netflix to Amazon Prime
or or any other really tech service but
also now that's made its way to
everything else we have meditation apps
like headspace where you get an
automatic renewal all the time you have
an app on your phone there's a very good
chance there's your subscription time
tied to it the idea is either that
you're paying with advertising right
you're gonna be looking at advertising
or you're paying with your own money and
no longer are we in these days anymore
really paying for that $0.99 app right
we're paying more now in subscriptions a
monthly recurring fee to the companies
so you're here to say Joanna pay
attention to when you get these
automatic payments do make sure that
you're actually using them because I
have so many apps that I know that I
haven't used in years and they're still
there absolu Matic payments my advice is
that every year we all sit down and we
do an audit of our subscriptions we go
through our credit card bills or our
emails wherever we see those things kind
of pop up we make this list do it in a
spreadsheet go old-fashioned put it on
some paper make that list and look at
the list do you use these things did you
do it yourself is that why you're here
that's why I'm whatever what happened
what happened to you I came here to tell
my personal story I made this list and I
realized that three or four of the
services I had I had just not used in
year like one of them being a eFax
service I am I am I on national
television right now that I had a fax
service very expensive fax as it was on
some credit card that I just don't use
that often and maybe I used it like once
or twice a year to come to my line for
the story was $1,000 fax yeah the you
know the promise of streaming services
was you get rid of a big old cable bill
and then you pay these little slices are
we at a point where it might actually be
cheaper just have cable for
entertainment I just did this math and
it is for me because I went through and
as a subscriber to subscribe to a lot of
these premium channels right Showtime
HBO now we're adding in things like if
you pay for Amazon you might want to
have some of the Amazon shows Disney's
gonna have some [ __ ] flicks just raised
its price Netflix raised its price we're
gonna soon have new new services from
HBO and other types of max services so
you have to look at what you pay for
cable what are the things you get what
are the shows you get for that that you
actually watch then compare okay if I
cut the cord
what other streaming services would I
want to get those shows on but I'm told
by my millennial friends Betty over
there says cable Millennials don't use
cable you don't that's true is it true
you don't have cable boxes I think I
think Millennials or younger people
might be a little bit more selective
about what they watch right and so they
may pick and choose then they may cancel
or start saying I'm gonna watch this
show on on Hulu but then I'm gonna
cancel it after I've watched it and they
pick and choose and also they're using
streaming boxes and I think that's the
main difference of what's gonna happen
here is what's the box we get this from
businesses love this because they get a
guaranteed monthly outcome that keeps
recurring obviously is it a good deal
for consumers it it depends it's like
it's like an all-you-can-eat buffet
right right if you go to the buffet and
you eat a lot that's great for consumers
we have to pay attention to your monthly
bill as the end you have to pay
attention to your monthly bill and you
have to be using those services and like
the buffet you know you can't eat all
that much I mean the $30 buffet you're
not that hungry well you're gonna
exactly uncomfortable if you go to the
Thayne you just get something from the
fruit bar it doesn't make sense right it
just doesn't know so you're just saying
do an audit people do it I said it do it
every month also one every month
I'm not everyone every every year if you
want to do it every month and you have a
lot of time on your hands every year go
through the list make sure you're paying
one other thing is just be careful all
of these services are doing the 333 days
yeah right that's how they get you out
for that and if you sign up for the 33
days put it on your calendar say okay
and of this is 29 days nobody's gonna do
that right now more than 80% of the
people underestimate how much they're
paying every month it's this pretty
stunning number all right Joanna's turn
thanks so much all good advice